gary neville is the best pundit on skye
[Music]
[Laughter]
i think he is i think he is
i think you are
sad
you know what i'll have to do it you
know what i'll have to change that
i don't know
i know i just i don't like it
i am
[Music]
what's going on well good ready for the
big season well i'm open soul mate but
you know we'll get there haven't this
year again
well it's always your year entire entire
year this year you're always going to
win it's always i'm just going to be
sitting back
politely and just there let's see what's
going to get thrown at me
liverpool will always be a bigger club
than everton
three
two
one
[Music]
i can't see things like that
i mean at one point jeff we're bigger
than little people when
well when we were founded there was no
liverpool and was the so we'll give it a
little quickly i think it must be bigger
if we're not even found and in part of
the eighties haven't been bigger than
liverpool
i'm not sure he you know the way jack i
was an evident fan then and you you
exactly you were never then why was
you'd never because at that time ever
were better than liverpool everton's
best team was 1985 yes and the following
year liverpool win the double
yeah
so that liverpool back on top so we're
talking about one year i'm not talking
about one you know we're talking about a
team and a time and then you can't
remember
when i was born in 82 you know you're
probably quite obviously you're older
than me you know as we can all say but
you're not going to talk me onto this
like you did to david's hey let's get to
the point right
did we're bigger
how would everton going to get bigger
than liverpool
how how is it possible success you
haven't gonna talk to you for 26 years i
understand that but it's going to happen
eventually it's going to come and am i
going to hopefully why have you got a
divine right because we're a big club
doesn't think so of course he does
you've got a small club
listen
as a manager at that time he's played
into a narrative to annoy the fans and
get on the back which is very clever and
very smart very similar to what i used
to do in fights so he actually thinks
everything are a big clue he knows he
knows everything okay so do you think
he'll call liverpool a small club this
year of course he won't
why not because he can't because they're
not a small club
because he sounds stupid because at the
time we were going through bad times
when rafa said that and that was the
best thing after 25 years
i was very lucky what happened to me
basically never told me
no so with this money in a new stadium
you think everton can become bigger than
liverpool eventually we can become
bigger than the pool yes we can in your
lifetime
that's a big question
i'm hoping so you know it's uh it will
never happen i'm quite confident evan
football club i will
in my lifetime i watch them achieve
great things i'm very confident
liverpool will win the league this year
three
two one
i don't see it
i don't see it
recruitment hasn't been strong enough
you're supposed to recruit when you're
at your highest and not your best to
help progress the squad and i don't
think liverpool's owners are putting in
the right amount of money i think
they're constantly on the tape meet
after that's the bottom shooter your net
spend is absolutely ridiculous it's
when they come for one of their players
because they know they'll take loads of
dough off them yeah and you'll get the
player at the club and you'll do
absolutely nothing but we are getting
back to california league now
right now i think the denomination from
klopp and the players it was really poor
last year van dijk's back
center back in the world do you think
the determination was but i don't think
it was no i said i think it'll be back
this season okay what do you think it
was gone last season no but i think on
terms of the problems that they had at
the back
it was just one of those no fans we know
how much the fans uh how important they
are to liverpool
if we look back at last season i think
actually no fans in the stadium affected
everton the most of all the premier
league clubs because we had one of the
best away records that i've seen well
actually better we were more games away
from home last season than we did than
the last time we won the league so
in hindsight
fans not being there affected those more
than anyone in the country it doesn't
actually matter if anyone's
undergraduate because no one knows each
other in the ground when they all arrive
anyway so there's just a gang of
foreigners who just come in have a party
and go back home when the game's
finished so i didn't think it really
made it does not have fun with evan but
he don't have the party something all
come from wales definitely don't have to
party for the landscape
if we shut the airports little scams
empty
let's just be totally
honest but
staying on board with what we're talking
about but i just i don't see them
winning it
i think man united will be a much more
formidable outfit this year thomas
tucker with chelsea as he's shown in
that champions league final is going to
be a serious threat if he gets off to a
good start he will be there all day
about and then no one can let you go
past peppa as good as corp is
i still think pepe is the best man in
the world you never mentioned evan
does plenty time yeah change
this is a better atmosphere than anfield
three
two
one
well we're obviously talking about
premier league nights on me so because
we're not in europe another premier
league day goes to parks much more for
those than than anfield
what's your experience with that then
give me give me examples so wednesday
night man united don't fix another one
milk wednesday nights meanwhile bloody
called the cream after it
wasn't involved with the cream of this
atmosphere soon
but we beat united london i don't can
get to the other so
amazing beating liverpool in the last
minute dan gosling in the cup
unbelievable atmosphere just celebrate
every mood
tones are like
i can go back to everything i would say
the derby
there is a better order and that's the
atmosphere at goodison the atmosphere i
used to love it i used to love playing a
goodness i prefer to play goodson in the
derby that i'm feeling because you know
but just if you won there it was the
best place to win it it really was i've
been there i've i've i've witnessed more
derbies than i can wish to remember i've
been down field i was there with gerard
scored the four goals or whatever it was
three or four and i've also been
accustomed to packing more standing
johnson does last season counts because
there's no fans there's a countermeasure
i mean you know it counts you haven't
won there with fans
for
not 20 odd years it doesn't mean
stopping them from okay then you didn't
worry in the premiership no fans were
there you didn't have it you didn't know
celebrating the year did you do your
parade so you didn't win the premiership
i'm sitting down
i'm going on a meet i'm just going i'm
just going i'm just going on your you
know thing here you've just said evan
didn't really win at anfield so it
doesn't really count you didn't really
win the premier league
you've got me there isn't it
[Music]
one nil boys
[Laughter]
[Music]
good question a trophy ultimately so if
rafa doesn't win a trophy he's not a
success yes i agree it's gone around so
far what was your initial reaction when
rafa benitez is announced as evident
manager
be honest
the first thing that comes to my mind
was this man's a winner he's always been
a win everywhere he goes he gets results
he knows how to play the first half he's
a gooder son
liverpool won their luck and liverpool
fans started chatting after benitez's
name yeah
you seen your foot picture they don't
know you haven't yet thought about this
he's thought about this
go on
how will that stadium react
there'll just be silence nothing we can
say
what can we do
what do you think that we like for his
first game do you think the fans will
applaud him give him a little or just be
nothing there
i've got him
football is bigger than any one man evan
football club is bigger than any one
scenario we are a religion we are a cult
we are a family we are everywhere we're
just ever in football club
is not bigger than ever with a
family why why would i have fans going
looking to where he lived and putting
bananas outside no families perfect
[Laughter]
i'll be honest with you
i wouldn't want to mind you nice and
managing managing liverpool
okay i wouldn't
but i get that and one who was loved by
man united i can't believe he's gone
there
what what is what is success then so i
think i think he can get everton in the
top six i don't think he'll get into the
champions league football but i think if
he could get everton into the top six
and get european football that would be
a success and i think that's the most
you can do yes you can win a trophy but
that that boils down to the draw
sometimes you get it yeah you know a
tough draw somebody get a lucky run you
get through so it's that's in the lap of
the gods but i think rafa benitez is
capable of getting evident in the top
six this season
not one every player would make it into
the liverpool 11.
three
two
one
then who what was his nickname with
napoli i've got a clue
wheels
wheels
island i think allen has been in
revelation fabinho is the best in the
league in that position
after that dominic calvert-lewin is
taking feminine's place there's no
there's no way for a birthday scores
more goals he's more prominent and he
doesn't set up enough he doesn't set
enough goals with that for me no will
but i don't care when you play a
frontier what do you want from me
forward your goals well liverpool's
goals come from the wide areas that's
how liverpool are set up so liverpool
has set up slightly differently i agree
with you in terms of calvin lewin but
he's completely different to for me so
it's a difficult one to
you know
it
you're one for me you know in the event
you know i haven't played one caliber
but in the liverpool team you don't want
famine because of how liverpool's sort
of abstracted
no no i agree and i think that could
definitely be a strong argument i'm a
really big fan of calvert-lewin god free
someone
now this is the problem with liverpool's
center arts no one's best in vega van
dyke and there's no one even remotely
closely good to he actually bails you
the man who's playing with him out of so
much trouble he i actually genuinely
believe he's the real captain of the
whole team
because he's the man he's to go to
he's the commander you know things are
going wrong i mean he's about nine foot
he's big he's intimidating he's
qualified
[Laughter]
i'm a big fan of this listen put it on
me meat you're going to keep as simple
as that yeah but i'm i'm a huge admirer
of i just think he's a brilliant
footballer i think godfrey just missed
out but i think in the next two three
things
okay well you've got golem as he's a
premier league when he's european he's a
winner i think godfrey's everybody's
going to go no i think he could be
there's no doubt but right now it's
difficult to say he's better than him
when he hasn't got things to pass
who
joe gomez yeah
yeah on last season pickford i'm going
on last season and now i know what i'm
in the euros picture no exception
exceptional goal i thought you said no
one's ever kidding you
accepting a goalkeeper i'll stand by it
jordan pickford is an exceptional
goalkeeper i stand by amazing feat but
everyone had a better season edition was
unbelievable i mean that pass that pass
alone in that european game
was it was alison's head at west brom
not just like seal it was that how did
you feel when that was yeah that was one
of the greatest moments in the season
i remember sitting there watching the
telly
with the kids and then this and just
thinking
as soon as i seen him coming up i went
it's in i'm telling you don't be stupid
daddy elvis don't be deaf dad i said i'm
telling you you don't understand it's
just cop-out behavior at the highest
level
he's going to put it in some what
happens jumps up in the air that big
stupid unbelievable wasn't it with the
f-line all over the place
exactly like he fell over as it went in
to make it more dramatic
so yeah just do you know what though
me out when talked to me yeah a part of
me just went you know what lad it was it
was emotional i just thought hold
maybe
gary neville is the best
one
[Laughter]
i know i just i don't like it
i mean gary neville is brilliant on tv
isn't he fantastic he is he's good at
everything he does he's really good you
know he's been he's fantastic i work
with him a lot
and
he's one of the funniest people i know
without
knowing he's funny yeah he just gets
that wound up by things he wants to
change the world he's up at four every
morning he has one four or five hours
he's just a lunatic he's involved in
everything
i do admire him
i mean he's
he just contradicts himself all the time
he's like this just sums gary neville
upright
we had getting ready for monday night
football show so we're doing the prep in
the afternoon
he's on the phone to someone trying to
buy a player for salford and at the last
minute the player
as i said he wants more money and he's
no chance tell that not a chance the
deal's off the deal's off me and them
then go on to monday night football and
he's arguing for alexis sanchez
asking for more money
to go to man united and not go to city
and i'm like i can't say what's happened
in the afternoon and so but i'm like
you are the biggest joke honestly
and that sums up he will change his
argument just to suit his own i think at
the time he said disagree uh you're
battling yourself then yeah yeah i
thought you know what
i
don't you didn't
saw those videos that was ridiculous no
i'm done
no i don't i'm not honestly i can't
leave it i'll tell you what i've got
right all right
can't believe why why is it because i
would go mental if suckers called the
winning goal
what about show campbell scored